Кіпр. Золоті пляжі і … "золоті" паспорти.
Ця острівна країна надає своє громадянство за гроші.
Це, зокрема, дає право вільно пересуватися територією всього Євросоюзу,
жити і працювати в будь-якій його країні, а також в’їжджати без візи до США.
Фактично 20 з 27 країн-членів ЄС пропонують отримати посвідку на проживання
в обмін на інвестиції різного масштабу.
А Кіпр і Мальта взагалі відкрито торгують своїм громадянством.
Кіпрський паспорт можна отримати за інвестиції від 2 мільйонів євро.
В Ютюбі чимало промооголошень про переваги придбання кіпрського громадянства.
Весь процес триватиме приблизно півроку, при цьому жити в країні не потрібно, обіцяють охочим.
Останнім часом умови отримання громадянства, щоправда, дещо ускладнили.
Інвестуючи в бізнес, тепер треба створити не п'ять, а дев'ять робочих місць для кіпріотів і громадян ЄС,
а сума так званого благодійного внеску для участі в програмі зросла з 150 до 200 тисяч євро.
Крім того, діти інвестора, які вже перебувають у шлюбі,
в програмі разом з батьком чи матір'ю брати участь більше не можуть.
З вересня цього року жорсткішими мають стати й умови отримання громадянства Мальти.
Нині потрібно інвестувати 650 тисяч євро у Фонд розвитку Мальти,
ще 150 тисяч - у держоблігації, а також придбати нерухомість за 350 тисяч євро.
А згідно з новими планами, вартість нерухомості має подвоїтися,
тобто треба буде витратити вже 700 тисяч євро.
Крім того, внесок у Фонд розвитку Мальти має зрости ще на 100 тисяч,
якщо інвестор хоче подати заявку на паспорт вже через рік після отримання посвідки на проживання.
Формально на Мальті треба прожити щонайменше рік, але на практиці,
за словами експертів, це майже не контролюється.
Кіпр запустив схему надання свого громадянства в обмін на інвестиції
після банківської кризи 2013 року.
З того часу, за різними оцінками, зокрема міжнародних організацій
Transparency International та Global Witness,
ця острівна країна заробила на "золотих" паспортах понад 6 мільярдів євро.
Надання громадянства, як і видача віз та посвідок на проживання
- особиста справа кожної держави ЄС.
Загальноєвропейських правил, які б регулювали ці питання, не існує.
Тож Єврокомісія може лише "висловлювати занепокоєння", що вона регулярно і робить,
коли у пресу потрапляють скандальні дані про новоспечених громадян Кіпру чи Мальти.
У Брюсселі критикують схеми отримання громадянства в обмін на інвестиції,
вказуючи на ризики в сфері безпеки, відмивання грошей, ухилення від сплати податків та корупції.
У Єврокомісії запевняють, що вони й надалі вивчатимуть,
наскільки подібні інвестиційні програми відповідають нормам ЄС,
і закликають Кіпр ретельно перевірити ще раз усі попередні заявки і вжити необхідних заходів.
На Кіпрі вже оприлюднили прізвища деяких власників "золотих" паспортів,
щодо законності отримання громадянства якими є сумніви.
Нинішній  президент Кіпру Нікос Анастасіадіс відправив список, в якому фігурують 34 прізвища,
лідерам політичних партій під грифом "секретно", який потім зняли.
На думку оглядачів, таким чином нинішня влада прагне показати,
що сумнівні "золоті паспорти" видавалися і їхніми попередниками.
За даними кіпрської газети Politis, у цьому списку є, зокрема, Ігор Коломойський,
його дружина і донька, один зі співвласників групи "Приват" Геннадій Боголюбов
та екссекретар РНБО Віталій Гайдук з дружиною.
Згідно з оприлюдненими даними, вони, як і інші власники кіпрських паспортів,
отриманих у період з 2008 по 2012 роки, підпадають під розслідування.
Спеціальна комісія визначатиме, чи були порушення під час процедури надання громадянства.
А це вже дані розслідування журналістів Al Jazeera.
На цьому інтерактивному графіку видно, особи з яких країн намагалися
отримати кіпрське громадянство у період з 2017 по 2019 роки.
Загалом майже дві з половиною тисячі переважно політиків та бізнесменів.
На першому місці - Росія, потім Китай, і третя - Україна, з якої походять 100 заявників.
Серед них - ексміністр екології України Микола Злочевський,
який фігурує у корупційних скандалах і кримінальних справах.
За даними розслідувачів, він отримав кіпрське громадянство у грудні 2017 року.
Минулого року Кіпр вже оголошував про рішення позбавити громадянства деяких власників
сумнівних "золотих" паспортів, серед яких був і російський мільярдер Олег Дерипаска.
Втім, тоді процедура позбавлення громадянства не була прописана належним чином.
Зараз вже внесено зміни у законодавство.
Але задіяти нові норми так би мовити "заднім числом" буде дуже складно,
і Коломойський та компанія мають непогані шанси зберегти кіпрський паспорт, відзначають оглядачі.
Тож нові зміни більше орієнтовані вже на майбутніхвласників "золотих" паспортів,
яких позбавлятимуть громадянства Кіпру, якщо вони приховали
або спотворили інформацію під час подачі документів.